Dr. Wallach is going to explain to you
tonight not only about cardiac myopathy,
but many other things. I pray that you
listen closely and carefully
because what you're going to hear may
save your life or the life of your loved
one.
Dr. Wallach in 1991 was nominated for
the Nobel Prize. He said many, many
fabulous things in his life.
There's no way I can tell you how
pleased I am to have him here in Kansas
City tonight, and I want to turn the
time over now to Dr. Joel Wallach. Would
you all give him a big hand?
How many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock?
Well, I'll tell you what, you're my kind
of people because I grew up on a farm in
West St. Louis County
back in the '50s.
And we start out with beef calves, and
if if you raise livestock, the only way
you can make money is if you raise a lot
of your own feed. For those of you who
don't have that experience. And so we
raised our own corn, and we raised our
own soybeans and our own hay.
And we had a truck come out from the
mill. And this truck would come out from
the mill, and it would grind up the corn
and the soybeans and the hay. And then
we would add sacks of vitamins,
minerals, trace minerals, and we'd make
pellets out of it. And this is what we
would feed the calves. In six months
time, we'd ship them to market to be
slaughtered, or we'd save back some of
the best ones for ourselves. We'd knock
them in the head and eat them.
Put it bluntly.
And it always fascinated me as a
teenager that we did that for those
calves, and in six months ship them off
to be slaughtered, or we'd eat them.
And we want to live to be 100 years of
age without any
aches and pains. And guess what?
We didn't take any vitamins or minerals.
And that bothered me.
So I'd ask my dad, I'd say, "Hey, Pops,
how come you do that for those calves
you don't do that for us?"
And he'd give me this good old Missouri
farm wisdom. He'd say things like, "Shut
up, boy. You're getting this farm fresh
food and we hope you appreciate it."
And of course I was very quiet then cuz
I didn't want to miss out on any meals.
Well, then when I went to school, I went
to the University of Missouri at the um
School of Agriculture and I got my
degree in agriculture.
And it was very interesting to me that
uh I got my major in animal husbandry
and nutrition. My minor was in field
crops and soils and then I got into
veterinary school.
As a freshman veterinary student, I
learned the answer to my question.
And the answer is this. We know how to
prevent and cure diseases in animals
with nutrition. And the reason why we do
that is because we don't have major
medical. We don't have hospitalization,
Blue Cross, Blue Shield. We don't have
uh
Medicare.
We don't have Hillary
to watch out for us.
If you're going to make money as a
farmer, you better know how to do stuff
yourself and you better uh do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can.
Well, to make a long story short, after
I got out of veterinary school, I went
to Africa for 2 years and I was able to
fulfill a boyhood dream. I was able to
be a Frank Buck for 2 years
and work with Marlin Perkins. Many of
you will remember him from the Mutual of
Omaha's Wild Kingdom. And he's a great
gentleman. And after 2 years of working
with elephants and rhino, people used to
ask me, "Are Are you a small animal vet
or a large animal vet?" Well, I would
tell them, "I'm a extra large animal vet
cuz I worked with elephants and rhinos."
Well, after 2 years, he sent me a
telegram and said, "Would you come back
to the Saint Louis Zoo and work with us?
We need a wildlife veterinarian at the
zoo for a special project. We're given a
7 and 1/2 million dollar grant from the
um
National Institutes of Health. And what
we need is a veterinarian who will do
autopsies of animals that die of natural
causes in the zoo.
I was just overjoyed to do that, and so
I came back and and did that. And of
course I would not only did autopsies
for animals that died in the St. Louis
Zoo, but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago,
the Bronx Zoo in New York, the National
Zoo, the LA Zoo, and so forth.
And my job again was to do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo, and look for a species of
animals that was ultra-sensitive to
pollution.
This is because during the early '60s we
had just learned about pollution and
ecological problems and disasters, and
nobody quite knew what to do. And so I
was supposed to find a species of
animals that was extra-sensitive
to this, and use them much like we did
the canaries in the mine. You know, the
old Welsh coal miners used to put a
canary in a little wicker cage and take
it down in the mine, and if methane gas
or carbon monoxide would leak into the
mine, the canary would drop off the
perch and die first, and the man knew to
get out before the mine blew up or they
suffocated.
Well, again to make a long story short,
over a period of some 12 years I did
17,500
autopsies in over 454 species of
animals,
and 3,000 human beings who lived in
close proximity to zoos.
And the thing that I found out was this.
Every animal and every human being who
dies of natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficiency.
And that fascinated me. Went back took
me back to those calves. I said, "Gee,
that's fascinating. Everybody's dying of
nutritional deficiencies." And we could
document this
at autopsy, both chemically and
biochemically and so forth and things
you saw with the eye at the autopsy
table. Well, that fascinated me. I wrote
75 scientific articles. I wrote eight
multi-author textbooks and one textbook
of my own cost 140 bucks for medical
students, and I'm sure the only thing
they do is use them for doorstops.
And I couldn't get anybody excited. I
was on 20/20.
Uh I was on 1,700 newspapers.
I was in magazines. I was in every new
network TV that you can think of. And
guess what? Couldn't get anybody excited
back in the '60s about nutrition.
So, what I did was went back to school
and became a physician
to use everything I'd learned in
veterinary school about nutrition in my
human patients.
And to no surprise to me, it worked.
Spent 12 years up in Portland, Oregon in
general practice.
And um it was very fascinating. What I'm
going to share with you tonight is what
I learned over those 10 12 years using
nutrition with my human patients.
And if you take home only 10%. If you
take home only 10%, it will save you an
enormous amount of unnecessary misery.
It will save you a gob of money. And
those of you in Missouri know what that
means. A gob means a lot.
And it will save you and in fact, it
will add on many healthful years to your
life. Okay, it'll add many healthful
years to your life.
Well, you can't do this. You can't get
these healthful years. You can't have
longevity. You can't live to your
genetic potential just falling off a
stump.
Uh you have to do some things. And the
first thing I have to do is convince you
that it is worth
doing these things. And I'm going to
start out by convincing you that the
genetic potential for human beings is
120 to 140 years our genetic potential
for longevity. Okay, 120 to 140 years.
There's no less than five cultures whose
people live to be 120 to 140.
Starts out in the Tibetans in western
China.
Uh these people were popularized back in
um by James Hilton. He wrote a book
called The Lost Horizon. Many of you
remember reading that was a Pulitzer
Prize winning book way back then. And
they did a movie of that 1937. It's a
very long movie, about 3 hours. You can
get it from any Blockbuster Video, and
I'll encourage you to get it and look at
it when you have 3 hours. It's a great
movie.
And the oldest living person that has
some documentation, I'm sure there's a
certain amount of exaggeration in there,
but there is some documentation was a
fellow, a Dr. Li, L I,
from China, along this Tibetan border.
And this fellow, when he was 150 years
old, quote unquote, received a
big certificate from the Imperial
Chinese government.
He was born in 1677.
150 years later, he was given a
certificate by the Imperial Chinese
government for being 150 years. And then
when he got to be 200 years, they sent
him another 50 years later, they sent
him another certificate. And supposedly
he died at age 256.
And it's people of that nature. He was
written up in the New York Times in 1933
when he died, in the London Times. And
so this is fairly well documented.
But he may have only been 200 years old.
I don't know if he was 256, but this is
the
um
person that led James Hilton to write
that story.
Then
there's in 1967
or '68, there was a remake of that
movie. It was a color version. If you
haven't seen that, it was called
Shangri-La. I'd urge you to see that.
Then in Eastern Pakistan, there's a
group of people called the Hunzas. And
these people are very famous for
longevity, 120 to 140. If you've been in
alternative health for any length of
time, you've heard their name at least.
Then in what is now Western Russia, used
to be the Soviet Union,
the Russian Georgians were made famous
during the '70s by Dan and yogurt. You
remember the old Crimea war
veterans, they'd get their uniform on,
they'd hold a saber up, and they would
get a cup of Dannon yogurt and smile a
lot, and you're supposed to make the
mental leap that it was the Dannon
yogurt that made them live to be 120.
Then just south of them, the Armenians,
the Abkhasians, and the Azerbaijanis are
famous, at least in in the Soviet Union.
They were studied for some 60 years
because they routinely lived to be 120
to 140.
In fact, in 19
uh '73, the January issue of the 19 of
the um
uh
National Geographic, 1973 January uh
National Geographic did a special
article on people who lived to be 100
and are older. And they featured these
people, and there's a great pictorial
article, you know, National Geographic
is very good about uh coming out with
pictures, and three of these dozens of
pictures that were in that article, I
remember one of them was a lady who was
136 years old. She was sitting in a
wicker chair with a big Cuban cigar in
one hand and an 8-oz glass of vodka in
the other, and she was partying.
She was having a good time. She was not
in a nursing home all slouched over and
and, you know, ready to have somebody
take another 2,500 bucks out of her
checking account. Uh she was enjoying
herself at 136.
Then there was a semicircle of couples,
boy, girl, boy, girl, boy, girl, and
they were celebrating their 100th and
115th and 120th
wedding anniversaries.
Then the third picture that I remember
is a gentleman who is picking tea leaves
up at the timberline in the Caucasus
Mountains in Armenia, and um
he is listening to a one of these little
transistor radios back then,
and according to his birth records and
and baptismal records, his military
records, and the birth records of his
children,
uh the National Geographic said that he
was 167 years of age, and the oldest
living person at that time. Well, in the
Western Hemisphere, the Vilcabamba
Indians in Ecuador are very famous. They
live in the Andes. And then in
Southeastern Peru, my favorites, the
Titicacas. I just like them cuz I like
the name. They're sort of east of the
Machu Picchu
the old community. The Titicacas live
around Lake Titicaca. And of course,
they're very famous for living to be 120
to 140.
Well, in May 11th, just about a month
ago, the oldest living American at this
time and documented through the Guinness
World Book of Records was Margaret
Skeete. She was from Radford, Virginia.
She died at age 115.
And she died of a nutritional
deficiency. You can tell that from her
her obituary.
Uh she died of the complications of a
fall.
What did she die from? Osteoporosis,
very good. She died of a calcium
deficiency. She had no heart disease, no
cancer, no diabetes, no other
infirmities.
But she died 3 weeks after a fall cuz
she didn't have enough calcium.
Very interesting. Also, her daughter
said that she had a craving for sweets
until she died. And that's a a disease
called pica. We'll talk about that in a
little bit, but usually when you have a
craving for chocolate, if you're a
chocoholic or a sugarholic, that means
that you have a deficiency of chromium
and vanadium. And we'll talk about that
in a minute. Then in a third world
country, in Niger, in Africa, a chief by
the name of Bower at age 126 was
eulogized by one of his wives. So, I
assume it was plural. He had many wives.
And she was bragging about him at his
death at age 126, he was still in
possession of all his own teeth.
Okay, so you assume that other faculties
are working, too.
Then, here's a gentleman from Syria at
age 133. He died in July of 1993.
And he was in the Guinness World Book of
Records, not because he was 133. There's
been many people live longer than that.
Not because he remarried for the fourth
time at age 80, but because he fathered
nine children after the age of 80. And
this meant if you add up 9 months for
each child and a year for breastfeeding
for each one and a year between each one
of the children, he was still fathering
children after age of 100. And that's
what got him into the Guinness World
Book of Records. So, there's still hope
for you, fellows.
Then those of you who like science, in
November of 1993,
those six biospherians came out of that
dome in Arizona. They were in there for
2 years.
Three couples. And they were supposed to
eat the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
whatnot and have no pollution in their
water or air or food. And when they came
out, they were examined by medical
gerontologists from UCLA, University of
California at Los Angeles.
And
they put all this information, their
physical and their blood work and so
forth, into the medical computers at
UCLA. And the medical computer said that
and projected that they could live to be
165 years old if they continued to do
what they were doing.
So, all of that just says to you that
there's a there's a possibility you can
live to be 120 to 140. And when I grew
up on the farm, we could grow 200
bushels of corn per acre. And with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did,
you could make a profit if you grew 200
bushels per acre. But if you only got
100 bushels per acre and put out that
same effort and the same fertilizer
cost, you'd lose money.
And so, I want you to think about it.
The average lifespan for an American
today is 75.5.
The average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is 58.
You want to gain 20 years statistically,
just don't go to medical school.
You want to live to be 120 to 140,
there's only two basic things. They're
real simple. Two things to remember.
Number one, you have to avoid the
pitfalls. You have to not step on the
land mines, I call it. And those of you
in the military, you know what that
means.
You do something stupid like step on one
of those things, you kill yourself
wastefully or unnecessarily.
And of course, if you play Russian
roulette, or smoke excessively, or drink
excessively, or wear a black sweatsuit
and run down the middle of the highway
at 2:00 in the morning, you're going to
get struck by a car. Uh all of those
things are foolhardy, but it's amazing
how many tens of thousands of people die
in America from doing those stupid
things every year.
The last thing I will share with you on
that subject of avoiding the landmines,
I'd suggest very strongly to you that
you avoid going to doctors.
And I'm going to back up that statement,
which is a pretty strong statement, with
a
um
statement from Ralph Nader's group in
January of 1993,
just about a year and a half ago,
uh January 13th. He put out a news
release based on a 3-year study on the
causes of death in American hospitals,
and it was 1,500 page report, this
3-year study. And I'm not going to waste
your time or mine by going over the
whole thing word for word, but the
bottom line says a lot. The bottom line
says a lot.
And here it is, quote, this is from
Ralph Nader now.
He's a consumer advocate advocate for
those of you don't know him, who watches
out for us. Quote, "300,000 Americans
are killed each year in hospitals alone
as a result of medical negligence."
Unquote. I'm going to read that figure
again cuz it's a huge figure. Quote,
"300,000 Americans are killed each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence."
Unquote. Now, he didn't say slipped away
quietly out of neglect in a corner
somewhere while they're waiting for an
X-ray. He used the word killed. When you
use the word killed, that means there
was a procedure the doctor was doing
went wrong somehow. That means that they
gave them a wrong prescription. They put
a decimal point in the wrong spot and
gave them an incorrect dosage. These
people were killed.
300,000. To appreciate how big a figure
that is, you have to compare that with
our military losses in Vietnam over 10
years where we lost 56,000 people over
10 years or an average of only 5,600 a
year
on a field of battle where people had
guns and artillery and explosives trying
to kill each other.
And millions of people poured out into
the streets and protested that war. We
had political anarchy in the last 3
years of the war.
Uh students took over universities and
colleges with guns and explosives.
National Guardsmen shot students at Kent
State in Ohio.
We chased a president out of the
presidency
for 5,600 military personnel a year. And
here's one profession that takes your
tax money
in the form of Medicare and Medicaid and
kills 300,000 of us a year according to
Ralph Nader and I believe him. He has no
axe to grind.
And you can go out in the street any day
of the week in any city and there isn't
even a crazy street preacher out there
with a sign that says protect us from
doctors.
I want you to think about that, folks.
That's number one.
You have to avoid stepping on the
landmine. So, there's a certain value in
treating yourself when you can.
Or preventing disease so you don't have
to get treated. Now, the second thing
you have to do, number two, is you have
to do the positive things. You have to
do the positive things.
And I'm going to
start out here by just putting a figure
up on the board. It's the number 90.
And you need 90 nutrients in your diet
every day. You need 60 minerals.
You need 16 vitamins.
You need 12 essential amino acids or
protein building blocks and you need
three essential fatty acids. You need 90
nutrients in your daily diet. Otherwise,
you're going to get a deficiency disease
if you don't have them in complete
numbers and optimal amounts.
Well, I can tell you that I was one of
those nerds back when I was in college.
I had a clipboard. We didn't have
computers back then. So, I had a
clipboard and I was one of those funny
guys with glasses and would walk up and
down in the student union there in
Columbia and say, "Do you take vitamins
and minerals?" I was still fascinated by
that and and of course people kind of
look at you crazy and say, "Well, yeah,
I take vitamin E."
And I'd wait for them to come up with
the other 89 and they didn't. They just
say, "Oh, I take vitamin E."
Well, today if you ask people, "Do you
take food supplements?" they say, "Oh,
yeah, I take Tums."
Because that's what you know they hear
all the time.
Well, again you need 90 nutrients if
you're going to make it. But the
newspapers know and the magazines and TV
and radio knows that we're interested in
health and longevity and and
supplements.
So, they all talk to us not because the
medical profession has asked them to do
that in their stead. The medical
profession doesn't say, "Hey, we're so
busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals, would you please
educate the people on nutrition?" They
do it because it sells newspapers.
Well, my favorite article of all time
appeared in Time magazine April 6th,
1992.
If you haven't read it, I'd urge you to
get it out of a school library, a public
library and photocopy it. Stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator. It's a cover article
that says, "The real power of vitamins.
New research shows they may help fight
cancer, heart disease and the ravages of
aging." Again, there's six positive
pages in here. There's only one negative
sentence and it was issued by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article, "What do you think What do
you think about vitamins and minerals
for people as food supplements?" And
here's what the doctor said, quote,
"Popping vitamins doesn't do you any
good." sniffs Dr. Victor Herbert, a
professor of medicine at New York City's
Mount Sinai Medical School. "We get all
the vitamins we need in our diets and
taking supplements just gives you
expensive urine."
unquote.
Well, to give you a Missouri translation
of that,
that means you're just peeing away your
dollars if you take vitamins and
minerals. You might as well wad up your
dollars and throw them in the toilet and
flush them away cuz you're You're
getting any
redeeming value from it. Those quacks
are just taking your money for those
vitamins and minerals.
That's what he was trying to say. Got
published.
So, it must be true, right?
I'll tell you what,
after having done those 17,500 autopsies
and 454 species of animals
from around the world and then 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren in
the not too distant future
great-grandchildren, I'd rather pee out
50 cents or dollar a day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals is pretty cheap
insurance.
Because if you don't invest in yourself
to the tune of a buck a day for vitamins
and minerals, guess what? You're going
to invest in the lifestyle of a MD
somewhere.
Because when you pay the medical doctor
your fee for going to see him,
not one penny of that goes to study
how to diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease in a little child
like who was in here earlier or how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer or prostate cancer in
adults.
Guess what that money goes for? Pays the
doctor's mortgage. Makes his Mercedes
payment.
It pays the tuition for his kids to go
to medical school at Harvard. You know
where Harvard is? Up in Boston.
Pays the tuition for his
kids to go to law school at Yale.
I believe because we've made doctors
wealthy
between 1776 and the Second World War,
the US government spent 80 million
dollars on health care and health care
research and studies.
Right now we're at 1.2
trillion dollars a year
for health care.
And it's free.
We all know it's free, right?
I like that lady. She says, "Like heck."
It's not free, but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff. I'll
tell you what, if we used a human type
medical system for the agricultural
industry and the livestock, your
hamburger costs $275 a pound.
On the other hand, if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans,
your monthly insurance premiums for a
family of five would be $10 a month.
You take your choice.
Well, I believe since we've made them
wealthy
through insurance programs and
government subsidies, I believe they owe
us something. I believe they owe us at
least as much as the
industries do according to, for
instance, recall notices. This was
started, of course, I don't know, 25
years ago when Ralph Nader learned that
the Ford Motor Company had made a Pinto
car with a rear-end gas tank that would
blow up when you got hit from behind at
20 miles an hour, fry everybody in the
car. And when people complained to Ford
Motor Company, they said, "Well, you're
just dumb for getting in a car accident.
We're not going to pay you for that."
Well, Ralph Nader says, "No, it's a
faulty design."
So, he went to a federal court and the
judge agreed with him and through a
court order forced Ford Motor Company to
send everybody a recall notice with a
registered letter, "Bring that car in
and we'll they'll fix it for nothing."
But they kill 300,000 a year and nobody
protests as long as we get ours free.
And that scares me, that attitude. At
any rate,
I've got a bunch of these recall notices
you should have gotten over the last
couple of years. I'll go through them
quickly. Number one is ulcers. How many
of you ever heard that ulcers is caused
by stress?
Okay, everybody's heard that. If you
don't raise your hand, you got
Alzheimer's or you're fibbing, right?
Well, we knew 50 years ago in in the
veterinary industry that
ulcers, at least in pigs, was caused by
bacteria called Helicobacter pylori. And
of course, we couldn't get one of these
high-priced stomach surgeons from Mayo
Clinic. In fact, we always used to yell,
"Hold the mayo!" when they'd say stuff
like that. And otherwise, your pork
chops would be $275 a pound to pay for
that kind of surgery. And we learned
that with a trace mineral called bismuth
and the tetracycline antibiotic that we
could prevent and and cure those stomach
ulcers in pigs without surgery. And so
that's what we did. Cost five bucks to
cure a pig of stomach ulcers with uh
bismuth, the trace mineral, and
tetracycline. Well, the National
Institutes of Health now, not the
National Enquirer, but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February of this year, February 1994,
and said, "Ulcers are caused by a
bacteria called Helicobacter pylori, not
stress."
And they can be cured They actually used
the cure word in this news release.
Medical researchers never do that. They
always say "Shows promising results" or
"May be beneficial." They use the cure
word, National Institutes of Health, and
they said "Can be cured with a
combination of the trace mineral bismuth
and tetracycline."
Well, for those of you don't know what
bismuth comes in, you can get it from
any grocery store or drug store. It's
pink, about $2.95 for an 8-oz bottle,
and it's called Pepto-Bismol.
So, a teaspoon a day full of
Pepto-Bismol and some Aureomycin calf
scour pellets, you can take care of
ulcers.
Now, you have your choice whether you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get whittled on. It's your choice.
Then, what's the number two cause of
death in Americans? Terrible disease
called cancer, right?
Now, when doctors get information on
cancer, you'd think they'd photocopy
that and when they send you that bill,
they should send you some photocopies of
this stuff. Well, in September of 1993,
the National Cancer Institute, not the
National Enquirer, but the National
Cancer Institute and the
Harvard Medical School up in Boston, did
a study on cancer patients, and they
came out and they said an anti-cancer
diet was found.
Well, anyway, they picked China to do
this study because in one province,
Henan province in China, they have the
highest rate of cancer in the whole
world. They took 29,000 people for five
years in this study.
And what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals at
double the recommended daily allowance
for Americans. Now, that's a trivial
amount. For instance, they use vitamin C
for one group and of course the
RDA or recommended daily allowance for
vitamin C is 60 mg. Double that's going
to be 120 mg. You can't go into a health
food store and find a vitamin C tablet
or capsule for less than 500 mg for an
adult.
And of course Linus Pauling, the
gentleman with two Nobel prizes, says if
you want to prevent and treat cancer
with vitamin C, you got to use 10,000 mg
a day. Well, all the doctors who used to
argue with him back 35 years ago were
all dead. And today Linus Pauling is
still 94 and he works 14 hours a day, 7
days a week on his ranch in the Big Sur
in California and teaches at the
University of California, San Francisco.
So, you have to make up your choice
whether you're going to listen to the
dead doctors or Linus Pauling.
Your choice.
Okay, vitamin C double the RDA, nothing
happened. Vitamin A double the RDA,
nothing happened. Zinc, riboflavin, the
trace mineral molybdenum, niacin,
nothing happened. In one group they got
a major benefit. In this group they got
three nutrients at one time. They got
vitamin E, they got beta-carotene, and
the trace mineral selenium. They Those
three were at double the RDA.
And if you get a half a percent benefit
in any nutritional or pharmaceutical
experiment, you've made a major
improvement in humanity's life. And so,
these articles get published. So, I want
you to remember that statistic. A half a
percent is major benefit. Well, in this
group that received the vitamin E,
beta-carotene, and selenium for 5 years,
deaths from all causes were reduced by
9%. Almost 10 out of every 100 or one
out of every 10 who were going to die in
that 5 years from any cause survived.
Then cancers, all cancers, 13% survived
who would have died without those three
nutrients.
So, 13 out of 100 lived who would have
died. And then the type of cancer that
was most prevalent in Henan Province,
stomach and esophageal cancer, 21% lived
who would have died. 21 out of 100
lived. Now, to me those are significant
numbers, and your physician, for the
number two cause of death in America,
should have sent every one of you a
photocopy that. At least given you the
information, even if he didn't want to
give you the advice, give you the
information, let you make up your own
mind.
Well, here's one I think is funny on one
hand, and on the other side it tells you
the attitude of physicians. This has to
do with arthritis. It was in
um September 24th, 1993 that it was
released. Again, it was from the Harvard
Medical School and the Boston VA
Hospital. How many of you in here have
ever been to a VA Hospital? Anybody in
this room? Okay, good. Well, you know,
the people who have been to a VA
Hospital, you have two opportunities to
give your life for your country.
Once on the field of battle, and the
other's in the VA Hospital, right?
Well, anyway, the title of the release
was chicken protein halts the swelling
and pain of arthritis in a patient
trial. And what they did they took
people who failed to respond in any way
to medical treatment for arthritis.
These people got gold shots,
methotrexate, they got uh aspirin,
prednisone, cortisone, and everything
else you can think of, physical therapy.
And the only thing left for them
was joint replacement surgery.
Okay, now before Harvard Medical School
and the VA Hospital was going to give it
to them they said, "Look, we're looking
for some people who are willing to
suffer for 90 more days, just 3 months,
because we want to try something, a
short-term experiment." And they got 29
volunteers. And what they did for those
29 volunteers who failed to respond in
any way to medical treatment for
arthritis was they gave them a heaping
teaspoonful of ground-up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning. Just a heaping teaspoon of
ground-up chicken cartilage. And in 10
days, according to Harvard Medical
School, all the pain and inflammation
was gone. These are people who didn't
respond in any way to medical treatment.
In 30 days they could open up a new
pickle jar that never been opened.
And 90 days, 3 months,
they had maximum return of function.
Now, here's the funny part. The funny
part comes by a statement of the guy who
was the director of that study from
Harvard Medical School, and here's what
he said, quote, listen to the words,
they're very important, quote, after 3
months, it was clear that the drug was
beneficial, unquote. Because it worked,
chicken cartilage had become a drug.
You can see he's thinking about patent
numbers, and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule, 20 patients,
and you can just see him calculating,
right?
That means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken,
throw away the skin and the meat, and
eat the ends off the bones, you're
practicing medicine without a license.
And if you go to a Kentucky Fried
Chicken in the middle of the night, in
the dark of the night, and you go to
their dumpster, and you root through
there, and you collect two 5-gallon feed
buckets full of chicken bones,
and you take them home with a hammer,
and you pound off the ends of those
bones, and dry your own cartilage in the
microwave, you know,
you're manufacturing a um
pharmaceutical, and the FDA's going to
put you in jail.
Well, if that's a little messy for you,
and you don't want to pay those lawyer
fees, you can go into any
grocery store and get some Knox gelatin.
Women know about Knox gelatin cuz it's
good for your fingernails and your hair
and your skin. It has the raw materials
for chicken cartilage.
Has the raw material for your cartilage.
It's made out of beef cartilage and beef
tendon. And if you take two of those
little half-ounce envelopes a day in
your orange juice, and you take it with
an ounce per 100 lb of body weight of
colloidal minerals,
next time I come back here in 3 months,
you're going to run up on this stage and
hug me and kiss me if you got arthritis.
How many of you ever heard of
Alzheimer's disease? Everybody's heard
about it today.
50 years ago, when I was a little kid,
there was no such thing as Alzheimer's
disease. It's a new
disease, one of those things that just
sort of happened. Now it's a major
disease.
One out of every two people who reach
age 70 get Alzheimer's disease. Pretty
scary.
Well,
we learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages Alzheimer's disease in
livestock. You imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their head saying, "Why
am I here?
Where is the feed box?" Because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day, you're losing money, right? So we
learned in the agricultural industry
how to prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease. We do it with high
doses of vitamin E and low intakes of
vegetable oil.
You say, "Well, like that's crazy. High
doses of vitamin E." Well, you should
have got a recall notice from your
doctor in July of 1992 because the
University of California,
I mean, we're talking about
sophisticated research medical school
here. University of California, San
Diego came out and said, "Vitamin E
eases memory loss in Alzheimer's
victims." Now, they're only 50 years
behind on that from veterinary medicine.
So you might be safer going to a
veterinarian.
Then how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone? Anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone? Okay, I see a few
in here. What's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally when
you got your kidney stone?
Give up calcium. No dairy.
No dairy.
None of those vitamin mineral things
with calcium in them cuz they have the
stupid naive ignorant belief.
That's pretty
intense.
They have the stupid ignorant naive
beliefs that the calcium in your kidney
stone comes from the calcium you eat.
When in fact, it comes from your own
bones when you have a raging calcium
deficiency, a raging osteoporosis, then
you get kidney stones. We learned a
thousand years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry, if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones in livestock, you
better give them more calcium. You
better give them more magnesium and more
boron.
Now, the reason is of course bulls and
rams, male cattle and sheep have special
anatomy. When they get a kidney stone,
they die. They call it water belly. They
die. When you and I get a kidney stone,
we just wish we were dead.
But no farmer is dumb enough to pay for
the feed for an animal and have it die
before you can either eat it or send it
to market. So, we learned how to prevent
those things. Well, you should have got
a recall notice from your doctor,
especially you people who've had kidney
stones. Your urologist should have sent
a notice to you.
This was about 15 months ago, March of
1993. It says
calcium limits kidney stone risk and
this is from the Harvard Medical School
up in Boston, by the way.
In a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head, researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones. In a study of
more than 45,000 people that who were
ranked into five categories, the group
that had the most calcium had no kidney
stones.
So, it took them a thousand years to
catch up.
Now, about five years ago when I started
out on this crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one time zone and the next
and
all over, I knew I was going to get
crazy out there uh
doing this. Last year I was on the road
300 days out of the year, 300 out of 365
days.
And so, I decided I needed to have a
hobby that I could take with me. Every
time I get a little wacko, I could go in
my room and do this hobby and I'd be
okay, you know, be kind of like having a
little piece of home with me wherever I
went. I wanted to have a hobby that
would
help other people. I didn't want to
collect baseball cards cuz I like
football and I didn't want to do just
crossword puzzles cuz good mental
exercise but wouldn't help anybody else.
And I couldn't take my compost pile. I
like to garden and the hotels don't like
that, you know.
So, I decided I was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and lawyers.
Now, as crazy as that sounds, remember I
told you that doctors live to an average
age of 58 and we live to 75.5. And
here's a group of people, professionals,
who pontificate you and tell you, "Well,
this is what you need to do. You need to
give up salt and uh no caffeine, and you
need to not eat butter and eat margarine
and do all these crazy things." And
they die at age 58 on the average. And
of course, all those people who lived to
be 120 to 140, they put a chunk of rock
salt in their tea every day, and they
drink 40 cups of tea a day, 40 chunks of
rock salt, and they cook with butter
instead of olive oil.
And they live to be 120. So, who are you
going to believe? The people who live to
be 58 or the people who live to be 120?
It's your choice.
Anyway, I got a few of them here, some
of my favorites. So, this is Dr. Stuart
Cartwright, age 38. He dropped dead in
his home. He was a family practitioner
uh of a ruptured aneurysm. That's a
ballooning of an artery that's a
weakened uh artery because of the uh
fragmenting or the uh brittle condition
of the elastic fibers in arteries.
Just like when you hit a chuck hole with
your car tire and you break the cords in
there and you get a balloon,
he dropped dead like he was poleaxed,
okay? Right in his home from a ruptured
aortic aneurysm. And we learned in 19,
oh, I think it was uh '57,
aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency.
We had a pilot project, 250,000 turkeys,
and we made complete food pellets where
you put
all the 90 nutrients in there. And in
the first 13 weeks, fully half of those
turkeys died. 125,000 of farmers were
out there every morning picking them up
by the bushel basket. They took to the
state diagnostic labs and their autopsy,
and they found out that they all had
died from a ruptured aortic aneurysm.
So, they doubled the amount of copper in
there. And the next year, they tried to
raise 500,000 turkeys, and they didn't
lose a single turkey from a ruptured
aortic aneurysm. And they ran that
experiment in mice and rats and rabbits
and dogs and cats and
uh calves and sheep and pigs and
whatnot. And guess what? They found out
that there's a whole series of diseases
that are caused by a copper deficiency.
Gray hair is the first sign. When you
start getting gray hair regardless of
your age, you got a copper deficiency.
You get skin wrinkles because the
elastic fibers in your skin are going.
Those little crows feet around your eyes
and facial and body skin wrinkles, you
can look like you're a little prune
drying up.
Okay?
Then, of course, there's the
varicose veins.
Varicose veins. That's caused by an
elastic fiber breakdown. Then, of
course, parts of your body begin to sag.
Under your arms, your breasts, your
bellies, your legs, all this stuff
starts sagging, and you can go to a
cosmetic surgeon, a plastic surgeon if
you want, but it's a lot cheaper and a
lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some copper.
Okay? Well, Dr. Cartwright may have had
a medical degree, but he didn't have
expensive urine, so he died of something
that even a turkey wouldn't die from.
Then, here's one. This fellow, he was a
doctor's doctor, Dr. Martin Carter. He
almost made it. He died at age 57.
Um he got his medical degree from
Harvard Medical School and his PhD in
medicine from Yale. Of course, um
he was autopsied by the best cuz he was
a doctor's doctor. It said quote, "The
cause of death was a ruptured aortic
aneurysm." said Dr. Jules Hirsch of
Rockefeller University Hospital,
unquote. What did he die from?
Copper deficiency. See, he didn't have
expensive urine, either.
Then, here's an attorney.
She was so famous. She was from Detroit,
age 44, Ellen Joyce Alter. Uh she was in
the New York Times obituary. She made
the big time. And uh of course, she
probably had steel buns because she
belonged to one of those private health
clubs. All these
gals want steel buns, you know, doing
their little exercises.
But, she didn't have expensive urine
because she died of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm.
When they don't do an autopsy, the
symptoms could be called a stroke or uh
subdural hemorrhage, but very frequently
they're caused by a ruptured aneurysm,
which is a copper deficiency. She didn't
have expensive urine. How many of you
here have ever heard of a guy by the
name of Stuart Berger? Stuart Berger, he
he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition. Uh he
got his medical degree from Tufts
Medical School, which is a very fine
medical school in Boston, not too far
away from uh Harvard Medical School.
And the books he wrote included The
Southampton Diet for Weight Loss. He
wrote Forever Young, 20 Years Younger in
20 Weeks, and How to Be Your Own
Nutritionist. And he died at age 40.
How'd you like to follow his dietary
practices?
He died at age 40
of cardiomyopathy, which is a selenium
deficiency. The same cause as white
muscle disease or or uh stiff lamb
disease, and any farmer can go to a feed
store and get selenium pellets or
selenium injections, uh things like
Selatok and BoSe, and so forth.
And Dr. Stuart Berger, a guy who wrote
five best-selling books on nutrition,
died of a nutritional deficiency.
He didn't have expensive urine.
Now,
you can prevent, totally prevent,
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day.
And if we don't do it, we're malignant
dumb, I like to call it. You're
malignant dumb if you don't take in 10
cents a day worth of selenium. It's a
waste of your life. That's one of those
land mines you can avoid.
The medical treatment of choice for
cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant,
but $750,000.
I want you to think about that. They get
the heart free from a donor.
They get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives.
They use $2.50 worth of suture material.
And they charge you $750,000
for that procedure. Now, 6 months ago in
LA when they had the earthquake, they
were putting people in jail for 60 and
90 days for price gouging for selling
these terrified people a gallon of water
for $4.
They put him in jail for price gouging
for selling him a gallon of water for
four bucks.
Now, to me that's entrepreneurialism.
You know, that's being in business for
yourself. If you had a a way to distill
water and make water and you had a car
and you could get in there and sell
those people a gallon of water for four
bucks. Hey, more power to you. Because
if you go to a 7-Eleven and buy a quart
of Evian water, it's $1.29.
So, four of those quarts is a five
bucks.
Kind of interesting, isn't it? They said
it was price gouging because those
people were terrified. We'll talk about
a person who needs a new heart. They're
terrified. $750,000.
We should put those doctors in jail. But
we bow to them because oh, that's
high-tech medicine.
Out of 270 million people in America,
you save about 50 a year. Is that
cost-effective? I don't think so.
I don't think so. Anyway, Dr. Stuart
Berger didn't have expensive urine. And
here's the last one and many of you may
know this woman.
Uh her name is Dr. Gail Clark. She was
age 47. She was the chief cardiologist
of the West St. Louis County group of
hospitals. Uh she was the chief
cardiologist for the um
St. Mary's Health Center in Richmond
Heights in St. Louis County. She was age
47. Guess what she died from?
Heart attack. A cardiomyopathy heart
attack. You can just see her walking
down the hall. She's got the stethoscope
around her neck. You know, this is their
little status symbol. Got my stethoscope
around my neck. Back when I was in
school, they folded it up very bravely
and put it in their pocket.
Boom! She falls down. She has a heart
attack right in the hall. And of course,
the nurses scoop her up and put her on a
gurney and they call the technicians and
another doctor. Code three. Code three.
Code blue. Whatever it is. And they whip
her into the room and uh you can hear
them Let's say you're a cardiac patient.
You're laying there. You're all hooked
up to the monitors and the IVs and and
you hear them say, "Okay. Tear her
clothes off."
Okay, stand back.
Didn't work. Turn it up. Stand back.
And then you hear that terrible sound
when you know that the
treatment didn't work.
The flatline when you know the heart is
gone.
And everybody walks out of the room
dejected and you say, "Nurse, nurse,
what happened next door?" And she says,
"Well, your cardiologist, you know, the
chief cardiologist of this hospital, age
47, Dr. Gayle Clark,
just died of a cardiomyopathy heart
attack." But you can see all the
patients are holding their gowns.
And they're running out of that hospital
leaving their watches and their shoes
and their
checkbooks and everything and their
plastic credit cards cuz they don't want
to get what Dr. Gayle Clark got.
To me, the Reader's Digest is a magazine
that never says anything negative or bad
about anybody or any group. It's the
sweetest little magazine that ever was.
The September 1993 issue
features an article that says, "Can you
trust your doctor?"
It lists 12 ways that doctors scam your
money. Now, I'll let you read 11 of them
yourself. I'll give you the worst one.
In addition
to their income from office fees and
surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization, in addition to all
those fees, doctors get a kickback from
the labs and the the x-ray labs and
clinics and hospitals, they get a
kickback of $421
every time they send you in for a CAT
scan or an MRI.
And doctors tell you, "Oh, we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine cuz if I miss something, uh you
know, one in 10 billion, you're going to
sue me. So, I do this just to protect
myself." Well, if it was just to protect
themselves and you knew them and they
knew you, 90% of the people say, "Oh,
just skip it, doc. If you don't really
think it's necessary, let's save the
money."
But they got something more than
defensive medicine to worry about.
They get 421 bucks in a kickback for
every time they send you in for an MRI
or a CAT scan.
Well, when I practiced for 12 years up
in Portland, somebody come to me with a
terrible headache, never had one, I just
walk up to them and tap him on the
sinuses and if they collapse to their
knees, I know they had a sinus headache.
Oh doc, why did you do that? Well, I
just wanted to That's a cheap lab test,
you know.
Then if they had Thank you.
If they had blood dripping out of their
nose
nose, I'd take a $35 x-ray to see if
they had a cancer in there.
$35 bucks and a free lab test
as opposed to 421 bucks.
If I wanted to make that 421 bucks, I'd
have been a good thief. What I'd have
done, I'd have built a chute right into
that CAT scan machine cuz I knew how to
build chutes living on a farm. And I'd
have gone out in the street and I'd have
got every homeless person, I'd line them
up in them chutes and I'd put soup and a
Big Mac at the end of that tube, you
know. And I'd say, "I'm going to get by
you a $1.50 dinner. I'm a good guy. I'm
going to buy you a $1.50 dinner. You
just got to go through this chute, go
through that tube and you get your
sandwich and your soup."
Man, they'd be flowing through there,
maybe 100 a day.
You know, I could start adding some
things up. It'd be a lot of fun. Anyway,
the average doctor gets $228,660
a year in CAT scan kickbacks. A quarter
of a million dollars a year. In any
other industry, if you do that
politicians, lawyers,
businessmen,
stock brokers, they get put in jail.
But doctors, it's okay.
Because insurance pays for it. Hillary
will pay for it. We don't mind if they
steal us blind. It's free.
Well, I remember I told you I was going
to tell you about pica.
Pica is a funny disease, p i c a. I'm
not talking about the type style that
you see in typewriters and computers.
But pica is a disease that farmers know
about. Uh in horses, it's called
cribbing when they chew on the feed
bunk, the wooden feed bunk.
You know, you better give them some
minerals, otherwise they're going to eat
that feed bunk.
Also,
uh in cattle, dairy cattle especially
where they're losing lots of minerals
through their milk all the time,
intensive milking, uh you'll see them
picking up big rocks in the creek and
chewing on them or they'll chew on
barbed wire or maybe you'll see them
walking down through a path with a deer
bone in their mouth or something or a
shingle. That's called pica, and a good
farmer husbandry man knows you better
give them some minerals otherwise
they're going to eat the barn or
something.
In human beings, we see this at funny
times. Pregnant women are notorious for
pica.
Uh the middle of the night they'll elbow
their husband and say, "Hey, you better
get up. I want some uh pickles and ice
cream."
They're craving minerals because that
fetus is pulling minerals out of their
body. They need some more minerals. And
so, it's it's recognized as a craving
for things like sweets and salt and so
forth.
We see this in pregnant women. I used to
have people come to my practice and they
say, "Doctor, I need to go see a
shrink." I said, "Why is that?" Well, I
wake up in the middle of the night and I
go outside with a spoon and I eat dirt.
I know, that's okay. Just make sure it's
clean dirt.
Then they say, "My my kid sits there
with a kitty litter box between his legs
and he has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box."
And then in housing projects, little
kids will eat lead paint off the walls
and they get lead poisoning, get
learning disabilities and bone problems
and anemia. And we're good, so we spend
$5 million to scrape the lead paint off
of there and repaint it with latex
paint. And all we have to do is give
those kids 10 cents a day worth of
minerals, be better for them and save us
5 million bucks.
It's your tax money.
And if we allow them to throw them away,
those dollars is kind of interesting.
Any rate, if you have a selenium
deficiency
and you don't want to wait until you
get to cardiomyopathy and drop dead from
a heart attack to recognize it, if you
look on your hands and look in the
mirror in your face, if you have liver
spots or age spots, and I see quite a
few from here,
you have an early selenium deficiency.
That's called free radical damage. And
fortunately for you, if you recognize
that, and you start taking in some
colloidal selenium in 4 to 6 months
those will all go away. You'll reverse
that in 4 to 6 months. And when they go
away on the outside they're going away
on the inside in your brain and your
heart and your liver and your kidneys.
Then if you have low blood sugar, how
many in this room have low blood sugar?
Anybody in here have low blood sugar?
Okay, about 10%. How many of you ever
seen a hyperactive kid who gets on
sugar?
Okay, about everybody in the room.
People who have sugar problems are like
alcoholics. There's good ones and bad
ones. You know, the good alcoholics are
one when they get two drinks they just
go off in a corner and go to sleep,
right? Same way with somebody with low
blood sugar. They eat a big meal or they
eat a piece of pie, 3 hours later they
conk out and go to sleep.
Then there's bad alcoholics. They're the
one that gets two drinks in them and
they get violent and raged and they want
to fight everybody.
Punch holes in the wall and you know,
big brave fellows and they kick their
wife and kick the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbor's tree
down and all these wild things and drive
reckless down the roads and kill people.
Those are the bad drunks. Well, people
who have blood sugar problems there's
bad blood sugar people, too.
They get a little crazy.
Okay, I don't know how many of you
remember the Twinkie defense.
Right? Remember where somebody murdered
two people?
And he claimed he ate a Twinkie 3 hours
before he murdered them so they let him
off because he got temporarily insane
every time he ate sugar.
Now, don't any of you try that.
Well, chromium and vanadium deficiency
will result in these sugar problems. Low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes.
Chromium and vanadium. Then a tin
deficiency, the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency are male pattern baldness.
I see a lot of tin deficiency in this
room.
Yes.
And if you let it go on for any length
of time, you get deafness.
Then there's a boron deficiency and you
gals should know about boron because it
helps you keep the calcium you take in
in your bones so you don't get
osteoporosis.
Boron.
Also, it helps you make estrogen. It
helps you fellas make testosterone.
If you don't take in enough boron, you
ladies are going to suffer miserably
going through menopause, okay? You're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms.
You fellas don't get enough boron, can't
make testosterone, you won't know
whether to lead or follow on the dance
floor.
You're going to be confused.
She's saying he's got a boron
deficiency.
Then in laboratory Oh, I should tell
you, too, that we said this on the show
today. Those of you may not have heard
it. Some of you didn't hear the whole
show.
The first symptoms of a zinc deficiency
is you lose your sense of smell and your
taste. You say, "Oh, you know, food just
doesn't taste good anymore." And you
don't have a cold or anything like that.
You say,
your wife says, "Well,
aren't you excited about dinner? I spent
the whole day in the kitchen cooking
dinner." He says, "Well, I didn't smell
anything when I walked in." You know
he's got a zinc deficiency.
On laboratory animals, there's some
seven rare earths. These rare earths are
trace minerals you need in lesser
amounts than you need trace minerals,
and they actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals. They've not been
proven in humans yet, but I'm not going
to wait 500 years for doctors to approve
it. They're still arguing over vitamin C
and calcium, right? So, I'm just going
to do it. Didn't kill any laboratory
animals, just doubles your life, and
it's not a drug.
These rare earths are called lanthanum,
praseodymium, neodymium, samarium,
europium, ytterbium, and thulium. There
must be a reason why they're named after
Old Testament cities. Well, remember I
told you we needed 90 nutrients. We need
60 minerals, we need 16 vitamins, 12
essential amino acids, and three
essential fatty acids. And of course,
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins, amino acids, and
fatty acids. Plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins,
amino acids, and fatty acids. But you
have to eat 15 to 25 different plants a
day in the right combinations to make
this happen. Theoretically it's
possible, but most Americans don't do
it. The average American thinks if they
eat some potato buds out of a Betty
Crocker box or eat a vegetable.
Okay, so you got to be careful what
you're considering a vegetable.
Then, of course, people want to do right
by their doctor and they eat low-fat
turkey breasts and they put a half a jar
of mayonnaise on there and they put it
between two slices of Wonder Styrofoam
bread.
Remember that stuff you can insulate
your house with
put in your shoes when you get a hole in
shoe. I remember when I was a kid 50
years ago, it was a lot of fun because
we have Wonder Bread. We didn't have TVs
back then on the farm. We didn't even
have dryers that went round and round.
So, the only thing you could do in the
wintertime was sit in the kitchen and
wonder at a loaf of Wonder Bread. And
they had the blue and red and green and
yellow balloons on there. And if you
read the labels as many times as I do,
you know it said things like helps build
bodies in 12 ways.
And about 15 years later the FDA made
them change it to help build your body
eight ways. Now, if you go to the store
and look at Wonder Bread wrappers, it
just says Wonder Bread. So, it kind of
gives you a clue.
So, even though this is theoretically
possible, it's not likely to happen that
you're going to get your vitamins, amino
acids, and fatty acids in proper
proportions from your diet. And so, if
your life is as valuable to you as mine
is to me and my children's my
grandchildren's is to me,
I would make sure that I take in all my
vitamins and amino acids and fatty acids
because I guarantee you won't make it to
120 or 140 if you don't.
You're just not going to do it.
Now, minerals are another story. We have
a tragic story when it comes to minerals
because
plants cannot make minerals in any way,
shape, or form. And if they're not in
the soil anymore, they're not in our
plants. We have for you when you leave
a free copy of a summary of US Senate
document 264. US Senate document 264 is
from the 74th Congress, second session.
And it says that our farm soils and our
range soils are depleted of minerals and
the crops, the grains, the fruits and
the vegetables and the nuts that are
grown on these depleted farm and range
soils are mineral deficient and the
people who eat them get mineral
deficiency diseases. And the only way to
prevent and cure them is with mineral
supplements. As US Senate document 264
74th Congress second session, it was
written and printed by the US Congress
in 1936.
58 years ago. You think it's gotten any
better?
No. It has not gotten any better, it's
only gotten worse. And the reason is if
you guys do what we did and and people
continue to do is we put NPK on our
land,
nitrogen, phosphorus, potassium and you
see it as these three numbers in many
combinations of of um
ratios. And these represent percentages
of these three nutrients, nitrogen,
phosphorus, potassium. And those of you
who don't have any experience on farms,
the reason why we do this is farmers get
paid for tons and bushels.
There's no subsidy that encourages
people to put 60 minerals back in the
soil. You get paid for tons and bushels
and for 40 bucks an acre, you can get
the maximum yield in tons and bushels.
It only takes 5 to 10 years to deplete
the land of minerals cuz every time you
harvest a crop, those plants pull
minerals out of the soil, many pounds
per acre every time you haul a crop out.
So soon those minerals are gone.
And if you only put back in three and
you take out 60, it's like a checking
account. If you only put three bucks in
your checking account every month and
write checks for 60, what's going to
happen to your checks? Boing, boing,
boing, they bounce, exactly. Well, I can
tell you that our health is bouncing
right now to the tune of 1.2 trillion
dollars a year because there's no more
minerals left in our soil. It's our
responsibility, each and every one of
us, to be responsible for our health and
consciously taking these minerals. Well,
I have a lot of people ask me, "Well,
what did these people do thousands of
years ago? They didn't even have
commercial fertilizers. What did they
do, these societies that had long-lived
people and whatnot?" Well, I want you to
think about the Egyptians, the Chinese,
uh people from India that lived around
these great rivers, the Nile River, the
Ganges River, um
the Yellow River in China. And what used
to happen was every year or so it flood,
just like it did here in northern
Missouri
last year.
And every time it flooded, guess what
would happen? It would bring silt or
rock dust from mountains from 500 or
1,000 mi away, and those people would
pray to every god they had, the water
god, the sky god, the wind god, the rock
god, to flood. We pray, "Don't flood."
They used to pray to flood because they
had their floods during the wintertime
and would put silt and minerals back in
the soil, and their grain was very
valuable.
King Philip, who is the father of uh
Alexander the Great, married the
12-year-old child queen of Egypt,
Cleopatra. She didn't look like
Elizabeth Taylor all made up and
beautiful costumes. She was a little
flat-chested teenybopper, not very sexy,
but Philip married her because
she controlled the best wheat in the
world. And if he wanted his Macedonian
army to conquer the world through his
son, Alexander the Great, he needed the
best wheat in the world so he could
march 20 hours a day, fight for 6 hours,
and win. If they used the wheat from the
depleted soils in Greece, they couldn't
go 20 minutes without saying, "Mommy,
pick me up." Can you imagine these big
Greek soldiers, "Oh, my legs hurt. Pick
me up."
And so, they knew the best place to get
wheat was from Egypt.
It was those floods that gave them those
minerals. And all those cultures that
came up with all the great art and all
the great technology came from those
places because they had more
intelligence cuz they had more
nutrition, more minerals. I heard
somebody say, "Very good." Well, you're
getting the picture. Well, what I'm
going to do here is I'm just going to
pick out a couple of minerals,
just a couple of them so you get the
idea. It applies to all of them.
Let's just pick out a common one like
calcium. Everybody knows about calcium.
Calcium deficiency will result in
something like 147 different diseases.
They're just different names. They're
named after people like Bell's palsy.
Bell's palsy
is you know, everybody knows about that.
One side of your face sags. It's not a
true stroke. It just affects your facial
muscles. It's caused by calcium
deficiency. We'll talk about in a little
bit. But everybody knows about this one,
osteoporosis.
It's the number 10 killer of adults in
the United States. It's very expensive.
It costs you $35,000 each for each hip
to replace. It's okay. It's free.
Insurance or Medicare or Hillary will
pay for it.
Costs you $70,000 for both hips. As
expensive as it is, it's the number 10
killer, remember?
Mrs. Skeats from Radford, Virginia, aged
115 years of age. She died of
complications of a fall.
We don't have osteoporosis in animals.
And it's because of farmers we don't
have osteoporosis in animals. It goes
like this. You have a a pasture with 100
cows in it.
And this year you didn't have any
calves. You can't repay your operating
loan. You're in trouble.
Right? Cuz you paid for the feed and the
vet bill and mowed the pasture and
fertilized and maintained the fence and
fed the cows and all this that and the
other.
You don't have any calves. You can't pay
back the operating loan make any money.
So you call the vet out and you say, "Do
I get rid of these cows? What happened
here?" And he examines the cow. He says,
"Nothing wrong with them." He says, "Let
me look at the bull." He says, "Aha!
Here's your problem. That bull has
osteoporosis of both hips. Can't breed
the cows. Didn't have any calves." He
says, "I'll tell you what though."
He says, "You give me $70,000." He says,
"I'll put two new hips in that bull and
next year you'll have some calves."
Well, the first thing that farmer says
is stand back, doc. Boom!
He blows that bull away with a deer
rifle. And while the kids are grinding
the kid the while the kids are grinding
the bull up with um
a grinder and cutting roast and steaks
off that bull, the farmer's chewing on a
straw and saying, "Now doc." Pushes his
Stetson up a little bit and he says,
"You know."
He says,
"You know I wasn't going to pay you
$70,000 for that old bull." He says, "I
could get a new bull every year for 70
years for that."
He says, "But every once in a while I
get a bull that throws good calves. I'd
like to keep him. Is there any way I can
prevent that osteoporosis thing from
happening to a good bull?" He says,
"Well, yeah." He says, "If you'll give a
bull calf 10 cents worth of calcium
every day after he's weaned, he'll never
get osteoporosis." Farmer says, "Now
wait a minute, doc." "You mean if I give
that bull 10 cents a day worth of
calcium from the time he's weaned, I can
prevent a $70,000
disaster?" He says, "Oh, yeah. It's that
simple." He says, "You mean all I have
to do is give up a half a cup of coffee
a day to do that?" He says, "Yeah,
that's it." He says, "I choose that
one." He says, "I'll give up the half a
cup of coffee." And that's what we have
to think like, okay? Then there's
receding gums.
Dentists and periodontists will tell you
that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums, you better floss and
brush after every meal. If you believe
that works, I have some ocean front
property in Montana to sell you.
If you all know your geography, you know
that doesn't work.
Now as a veterinarian, I've seen
hundreds of thousands of animals of all
kinds, mice, rats, rabbits, dogs, cats,
sheep, pigs, horses, lions, and tigers,
and bears, and they don't get receding
gums.
And they don't floss.
Now they do get funky breath, but they
don't get receding gums. Well, if you
want to smell something, you just let a
camel breathe on you, boy.
Well, the reason we don't have receding
gums in livestock is because we've dealt
with the osteoporosis problem. Receding
gums is not a deficiency of flossing.
It's in fact osteoporosis of the jaw
bones and of the facial bones. So, if
you have gingivitis or receding gums,
you have advanced osteoporosis. Those
bones around your teeth are melting away
little bit by little bit every day. And
if you take your teeth out at night and
put them in a glass next to your bed and
that fizzy stuff, you have major
advanced osteoporosis because all your
bone has melted away.
Okay? Then there's arthritis.
We talked about that a little bit
earlier. Remember the chicken cartilage
or the Knox gelatin? 85% of all
arthritis is caused by osteoporosis of
the joint ends of the bones. You're
talking about degenerative arthritis,
osteoarthritis, sciatica, lumbago,
rheumatism, all those sorts of things.
Um they're caused by osteoporosis of the
joint ends of the bones. I want you to
think about something for a minute.
If you don't take a pain reliever or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis,
let's say you get arthritis of the hips,
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit, aren't you? You're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches.
You're going to
favor it so you don't put any weight on
it.
I want you to think about that for just
a second because then I want you to
think about driving your tractor in a
field or you're driving a Mercedes down
the highway, either one, doesn't matter.
Whichever you love more.
And um let's say you didn't put the nut
on that oil pan real tight and all the
oil drained out.
And that light on the dashboard comes on
says, "I'm getting hot. You better give
me some oil."
And that light irritates you. So you
stop, you open up the hood, you get your
clippers out, you know, your fence
clippers, and you clip the the wire to
that light, and you close the hood, and
you just keep driving.
Would you do that to your tractor or
your Mercedes? No, you wouldn't.
But we take those pain relievers for
arthritis and we go out there and square
dance and do the Texas two-step and do
our 5-mi walks and our aerobics. "That
pill works real good, Doc, cuz it killed
my pain." And you're just wearing that
thing off faster and faster.
Then your doctor's really going to get
rich because you need
joint replacement surgery.
Then there's hypertension. This is one
of my favorites, so I'll put a star over
here.
Hypertension is high blood pressure.
What's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure? Give up salt. Everybody knows
that one. That's been ingrained in our
head.
Well, they must think we're dumber than
cows because what's the first thing you
put out for your livestock is about that
big. A salt block. No farmer is going to
be economically viable if you don't put
a salt block out for your livestock.
They're going to die. Kind of your going
to veterinary bills are going to go
crazy.
But we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt. You can get everything
you need out of your lettuce and your
whole wheat bread and stuff like that.
Well, don't believe that one either. If
you believe that, I got some more
oceanfront property in Montana for you.
Remember those long-lived people put a
big chunk of rock salt the size of a big
black concord grape in every cup of tea
and they drink about 40 cups of tea a
day cuz they live at high altitudes
where it's very dry. They have to keep
hydrated.
And they put butter
in their tea. They put two pats of
butter and a chunk of rock salt.
They don't put the pink stuff or the
blue stuff
or skim milk or what do they call it?
Creamora or whatever it is.
Okay. Guess Guess what? The doctors who
lived to be 58 tell you no salt, no
butter.
The people who lived to be 120, they put
in butter and salt. So, you got to make
some choices.
Well, they took $30 of your tax money
and 2 years ago after 20 year study,
they came out and said that they took
5,000 people with high blood pressure.
They took them off their medication and
put them on a reduced salt diet, a
restricted salt diet, and they all died.
No big surprise, but somebody got a PhD
degree and everybody was happy, right?
But when they looked at this results,
they said that oh, only 99.7%
of the people didn't get any results
from that before they died. 0.3% did get
some result, dropped their blood
pressure one point before they died by
restricting their salt. So, the referees
who judged that article said, "Oh,
doesn't matter. You might as well let
high blood pressure patients eat salted
peanuts and dill pickles and salt their
food to taste because it doesn't
matter." In fact, worrying about the
salt is more stress than taking the
salt. Then they had a control group with
5,000 people with high blood pressure
and they doubled their RDA of calcium
and they stopped the experiment in 6
weeks because 85% of them were cured of
their high blood pressure just by
doubling their calcium intake. Now, they
didn't cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication, but what they did
was they went to the doctor and said,
"You don't need this medication anymore.
What are you doing?" He said, "Well, I'm
on this experiment where I double my
calcium intake." Anybody get a recall
notice from your doctor saying it's okay
to salt your food to taste and please do
double your calcium intake. Anybody get
that? Not a single one. That's very
interesting.
Then, of course, there's insomnia.
That's where you roll around all night
and you get your
you wake up in the morning, you're more
tired when you went to bed and that's
insomnia. Of course, doctors have two
treatments for that. They have Halcion,
which is a sleeping pill, and they have
barbiturates. They kill about 10,000
people a year with overdoses of those
things, but that's okay. It's a
prescription and they're watching out
for us.
And remember
remember George Bush when he went to
Japan, they gave him some Halcion so he
could sleep on the way to Japan because
of the time difference and when he woke
up, one of the the side effects of
Halcion is nausea and vomiting.
I don't know how you say it in Japanese,
but it was very dramatic on world TV,
right? Not very presidential.
And so, I'm sure that's why he lost the
election because he puked over that
Japanese ambassador.
And then, of course, there's kidney
stones
and then there's a bone spurs, heel
spurs
and calcium deposits. Again
physicians will tell you
the first thing to give up nutritionally
is calcium and dairy because they have
this foolish belief, this stupid belief,
the ignorant belief that the calcium in
kidney stones, bone spurs, heel spurs,
and calcium deposits come from uh
your diet, when instead it only comes
from your bones when you have a raging
osteoporosis. And when you get these
things, you need more calcium, not less.
Then there's cramps and twitches.
You wake up in the middle of the night
and your foot is all cramped up around
your neck, and you say, "Lord, take me
from the knee down. I'm not going to
make it till morning." We've all
experienced that.
That's very common.
Then there's PMS, premenstrual syndrome.
You know, you the emotional and physical
stuff. The medical treatment of choice
for PMS is what we call a hysterical
ectomy. It's been shortened to
hysterectomy. That's a 100-year-old
treatment, and the doctors do about
285,000
unnecessary hysterical ectomies a year,
but it makes Mercedes payments, so they
do them. Even the AMA said they're
unnecessary, but they don't take their
licenses away, and people keep going to
them. You imagine a poor woman in her
30s, she says, "Doc, you got to do
something. Every time I go out to hang
out the clothes, my neighbors' kids run
down the basement screaming, 'Witch!' My
own kids think I'm crazy. My husband's
leaving me. I'm going to lose my job.
You got to do something." Well,
University of California, San Diego came
out 3 years ago now and said, "If you
just double the RDA of calcium intake,
you get rid of 85% of the emotional and
physical symptoms of PMS."
And when that came out, there were huge
lines around the health food stores
around the blocks, and people had
sleeping bags cuz they closed before
they all got their calcium, and every
person in line was a man.
They were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that.
Okay, and lastly is low back pain.
85% of Americans get low back pain,
whether you work on a computer or you
unload hay or you drive big trucks,
doesn't matter. Low back is a big
problem. Low back is just osteoporosis
of the vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot because if your disc
doesn't have anything to hold on to,
your vertebrae have melted away, what's
going to happen to the disc? Especially
if you have a copper deficiency because
they're made out of elastic fibers,
they go like a water balloon with a lot
of pressure on them.
Well, I just want you to look at this
quickly before we do the last mineral.
Low back, you go to an orthopedic
surgeon or rheumatologist, you might get
a muscle relaxant, you might get Valium
and a muscle relaxant, you get a
laminectomy, you get your vertebrae
fused, you might get a disc operation.
They don't tell you that 75% of the time
you'll never be the same again.
Right? PMS, you go to your OBGYN,
you can um
uh go to an internist, you can go to a
family counselor, a shrink, or divorce
attorney. Cramps and twitches, you go to
a neurologist, you go to a sports
medicine doctor, an internist. Bone
spurs, heel spurs, calcium deposits, you
go to a rheumatologist, an orthopedic
surgeon, or a podiatrist. Kidney stones,
you go to a urologist or an internist or
a surgeon. Insomnia, you go to a shrink
or a um sleep clinic or an internist.
Hypertension, you go to a cardiologist,
an internist, or a uh surgeon.
Arthritis, a rheumatologist, a
orthopedic surgeon, or an internist.
Receding gums, you go to a dentist or a
periodontist. Osteoporosis, you go to
all those health specialists including a
tongue salesman.
For nothing more than a calcium
deficiency. It cost you 10 cents a day
to deal with. Now, on the average
because Americans have insurance and we
have Medicare and Medicaid,
we spend on the average $25,000 to
$250,000
and we undergo five to 10 surgical
procedures a year for a calcium
deficiency and we beg the doctors to do
it. We beg the doctors to do it. Well,
it's our choice. The last one I'll share
with you is diabetes. Everybody's
touched by diabetes. It's the number
three cause of death in adults in the
United States. Number three cause of
death. And it has terrible complications
and side effects, diabetes.
The side effects include blindness of
many kinds.
Then there's a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant. There's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds. And
of course that contributes to number one
cause of death. Which is the number one
cause of death? Uh then there is
amputations. Everybody ought to have one
of those cuz they're totally paid for in
their health thing. Okay, they assume
that you're not just going to get one
cuz you want to get everything on your
health benefits.
And then you shorten your life because
if you have diabetes on the average, you
have a shorter lifespan than someone who
doesn't have diabetes. Now,
we learned in 1957
in the animal industry that we could
prevent and cure diabetes with two trace
minerals.
That's a pretty profound statement. That
we could prevent and cure diabetes with
two trace minerals in 1957 in animals.
It was published in Federation
Proceedings, which is the official
journal of the American Science, the
National Institutes of Health. The
official monthly journal was August
1957.
Well, the two trace minerals that you
can get to prevent and cure this
are chromium and vanadium. Vanadium
alone, according to the University of
Vancouver, British Columbia Medical
School, vanadium alone will replace
insulin
in adult onset diabetics, which
represent 85% of all diabetics. Of
course, they can't quit their insulin
cold turkey. They got to gradually wean
off of it. Takes 4 to 6 months for most
people to slowly wean off of insulin if
they're taking in adequate amounts of
chromium and vanadium. I've seen it work
on hundreds and hundreds of people. Now,
to me this is criminal
because if you write to Hills
Packing Company that makes Science Diet
Dog food that are right over here in
Topeka, Kansas. I don't know if I'm
pointing west, but that way, okay.
They're all saying that way.
Topeka, Kansas, so they manufacture
Science Diet dog food and other Science
Diet product, high-tech foods for
animals.
If you write them and say, "How many
minerals exactly is in Science Diet for
dog food?" They'll write you back and
say there's 40 minerals.
You write to Checkerboard Square in St.
Louis, Ralston Purina and say, "Just how
many minerals are in your rat pellets
for laboratory rats?" And they'll say
there's 28 minerals.
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new $100 bill if you can find me a human
infant formula in a grocery store that
has more than 11.
So, our dogs get 40 minerals.
Remember, that's what Mike Murphy was
saying, "His dog never seems to get
sick." Cuz he's getting this canned dog
food with all these vitamins and
minerals in there.
So, our dogs get 40 minerals, our rats
get 28 minerals, and our human infants
get 11.
Is that fair?
No, that's called fraud.
Doesn't matter if you're talking about
SMA, Similac, Isomil, ProSobee. In fact,
that's why they call Similac Similac cuz
it lacks everything.
Okay, if I've convinced you that you
have to consciously take in all the
minerals yourself, that you can't depend
on your food, and certainly you can't
depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled,
there's three types of minerals that you
have to be concerned about. One is
metallic minerals. Metallic minerals are
essentially ground up rocks. Metallic
minerals are things like oyster shell,
egg shell, dolomite, limestone,
uh calcium carbonate, clays of various
kinds, montmorillonite clay, seabed
minerals. They're all atoms.
They're only 8 to 12% absorbable. When
you reach age 35 to 40, it drops down to
3 to 5%.
And I have to tell you a story here.
Some of you heard this on the show
today.
I ran into a guy at a meeting like this
up at Grand Rapids, Michigan.
And this fellow owns a porta potty
business. You know, that's that green or
blue colored outhouse. Man, if we'd only
had one of those back when I was a kid.
We had these ones with splinters, you
know, in the
in the wood.
Anyway,
he said, "I see some something that that
describes that in my porta potty
business." I said, "What's that?" He
says, "Well, when we take those things
back to the shop to clean them out with
a pressure hose, he says we put a
1/4 in grid underneath them because kids
throw rocks and sticks and toys in
there. And if we don't put a grid there,
it blocks up the sewer system. It costs
us thousands of dollars to fix it." He
says, "Every time we clean one of those
out, we find hundreds
of vitamin tablets."
I said, "Well, how do you know they're
vitamin tablets?" He said, "Well, it's
really easy." He says, "Right on the
coating it says Theragran M, One-A-Day,
Centrum."
He says, "Come here." He takes me out in
the back of the shop and there's this
literal mountain
of all these vitamin pills he got out of
his porta potties. That's because you
can't absorb metallic minerals. If you
read the labels on those multiples, they
say
your iron that comes in the form of iron
oxide.
What is iron oxide?
Rust.
You might as well just go out to an old
railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it, and you're going to get
your iron supplement. Well, that's what
they're giving you.
Well,
I'll show you how bad it is if you take
something like calcium lactate, which is
which is a common metallic mineral.
Let's say it's a calcium tablet calcium
lactate 1,000 mg.
If you take two of those, you're not
getting 2,000 mg of calcium. In fact, I
have people all the time say, "Well, I
took lots of calcium, Doc. I hear you on
the radio talking about calcium and
arthritis, and I took 2,000 mg of
calcium a day. It didn't help my
arthritis. In fact, it got worse." I
said, "What kind of calcium are you
taking?" They said, "Calcium lactate."
Well, there's your problem because only
250 mg of that is metallic calcium.
So, let's say you absorb 10% of that,
then the other 750 mg is lactose or milk
sugar.
So, 10% of 250
is 25. So, if you take two of those
tablets, you're not getting 2,000,
you're getting 50 mg.
So, to get what you need, you need to
take 90 of those tablets a day. You need
to take 30 with each meal, and you got
59 more minerals to go.
Then there's those people who want to do
things naturally. Let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 lbs of spinach.
And let's be fair, let's see if you can
get 1,000 mg of magnesium.
I picked magnesium in it because in
green leafy vegetables, you have a lot
of magnesium because of the chlorophyll,
right? It's part of the chlorophyll
molecule. And any pound of anything, you
got 454 g. In 10 lbs of spinach, you got
4,540 g, of which most of that, 97% is
water. And let's say you have 1 g of
chlorophyll in that 10 lbs of spinach,
there's 50 mg of magnesium. You got to
divide that into the thousand you want,
you get a factor of 20, which you
multiply times the 10. You have to eat
200 lbs of spinach, you got 58 more
minerals to go.
Okay, so
you got to be a pretty big person to
accomplish all this. Even as big as I
am, you can't get it done. So, I prefer
to supplement rather than do those
things.
Then of course, during the '60s, the
agricultural industry came up with
chelated minerals. Chelated minerals
because farmers aren't dumb enough to
pay for a dollar of something that goes
into an animal's mouth and have 99 cents
come out in the manure. So, I have to
really thank farmers for being that
clever. And chelated minerals are just
metallic minerals with an amino acid or
protein or enzyme wrapped around the
metal atom. It increased the
absorbability to 40%.
Then the health food industry jumped on
that right away cuz it was a major
improvement in absorbability of
minerals.
The most efficient way to absorb
minerals is the colloidal form.
Colloidal minerals are 98% absorbable.
Two and a half times more available than
chelated minerals and 10 times more
available than metallic minerals.
And they're very interesting. They're
liquid, they can only be liquid. Can't
be pills, powders, or
capsules. They're very small particle
size are 7,000 times smaller than a red
blood cell and they're negatively
charged. Every particle is negatively
charged. Your intestinal lining is
positively charged. So you actually have
an electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals around the
lining of your intestine. These three
things together give you the 98%
absorbability. Now plants have a very
interesting part to play in colloidal
minerals.
Remember we said that plants cannot
create minerals. If they're not in the
soil, plants can't make them.
Remember that US Senate document 264
says they're not in the soil anymore.
Anyway, metallic minerals are taken up
by plants when they're in the soil.
Plants convert them in their tissues to
colloidal minerals and this is how we
store minerals in our body. This is how
we use minerals in our body. This is how
we transport minerals from the storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal form. Well, our plants, our
crops don't have much in the way of
colloidal minerals in them cuz we don't
have any metallic minerals in our soil.
Is this important? Well, yeah. These
long-lived cultures who live to be 120
to 140, they have certain common
denominators. They all live in high
mountain villages that are above 8,500
to 14,000 ft in elevation.
They all have less than 2 in of
precipitation a year. They don't have
any rain, they don't have any snow.
They don't have any dew. Okay, very very
dry places. And guess what? They get all
their drinking water and all their
irrigation water for their crops from
what we call glacial milk. Glaciers in
every one of those communities grind up
the parent rock of those mountains about
4 in a year. There's more than 60 to 72
minerals in each one of those places.
The water that comes out from underneath
those glaciers is not clear like Perrier
or Evian water or Poland water or geyser
water. You take a glassful of it up and
then hold it up, it looks like Jersey
milk. I mean, it is either yellow,
white, or white blue. It looks like milk
and is called in Titicaca. See, I got to
say it again. In Titicaca or Tibet, they
all call it
glacial milk cuz it looks like milk. And
not only have they consumed it, drunk
it, and got 8 to 12% until they were 35
to 40, then 3 to 5% absorption for 2,500
to 5,000 years, depending on the
culture, more importantly, they have
irrigated with it year after year, crop
after crop, generation after generation
for 2,500 to 5,000 years. They have no
diabetes, they have no heart disease, no
high blood pressure, no arthritis, no
osteoporosis, no cancer,
no cataracts, no glaucoma. They have no
birth defects.
They have no jails full of drug addicts.
They have no taxes, they have no
doctors.
Yet, they live to be 120 to 140 without
disease. Are these colloidal minerals
important? You bet your life they're
important. And every time you don't take
them in every day, you're chopping off a
few hours or a few days of your life.
Okay. Now, most people are not going to
go to Hunza or Tibet or Titicaca
because we don't have Kenmore kitchens
there or even Saturn cars or TV changers
uh channel changers or electricity. They
don't have insulated houses, they don't
have central heating or air
conditioning.
But, what they do have is colloidal
minerals.
This is Dr. Wallach with a final
message. Information gives you the
ability to make decisions with
confidence. I hope you've enjoyed my
message. By giving your body the proper
raw materials every day, you'll be
taking the necessary steps in living
healthier and living longer. Make the
decision to take control of your
personal health and longevity program
today.
Colloidal minerals are not like
antibiotics. You don't get a
prescription which you use for 10 days
and then you're done. Your prescription
for colloidal minerals should only
expire when your need for oxygen
expires. You need to supplement your
diet with the 90 essential nutrients
each and every day of your life.
Millions of people have heard my message
all across the world and have now
decided to make the consumption of
colloidal minerals a daily ritual. Just
as there are many manufacturers of
aspirin, there are now many
manufacturers of vitamins and mineral
supplements. Be sure to get your liquid
colloidal minerals derived only from the
very best organic plant source deposits.
Colloidal minerals are the mineral
source our bodies were designed to use,
not ground up rocks. Since you will most
likely be supplementing your diet each
and every day, don't get caught paying
retail prices. My daddy always said,
"Why pay retail when you can buy
wholesale?" One of my trusted colleagues
will show you how to purchase the
highest quality products wholesale so
you can save gobs money off the retail
price each